just that if you're born in Pacific
Heights in San Francisco you are much
more likely to end up being like your
parents that owned a house in Pacific
Heights etc versus if you're born in a
zip code where there's 700 homicides
right yeah yeah and I'm sure everyone is
renting so no you probably yeah things
like that that like that so and so and
then you think about what's going on in
that in that you know for the base
physiological needs for the person who
PAC Heights versus the person in South
Side Chicago and you can literally
immerse yourself in the shoes of what it
would be like to be each one of those
people and then to say say are the
opportunities really equitable are they
the answer is clearly no and so we're
not saying we're not saying equal
outcomes for everybody we're saying
equal opportunities for people and how
do we actually get there and so so so
just unpacking that that that basic
physiological physical needs in this
roll of the dice so that's that's just
how I compare to roll the dice if you're
if your dice are rolled and you end up
in South Side Chicago versus if your
dice are rolled you end up in PAC
Heights that is a significant life
outcome difference and if we truly
believe in a roll of the dice and
humanity in general how can we decide to
purchase a third boat instead of go and
try and hire 50 people to solve a
problem in the world and so that's kind
of this this conversation that I've been
trying to have on the show and I just
like to maybe hear your thoughts this
world the dice how could you not try and
solve these basic physiological needs
for other people on this planet
shouldn't it be a fire under all of our
asses are they just not spiritually
enlightened enough to get that what's
what's what's going on again we've
talked about like this vested interest
in keeping your idea of the world safe
and I think there's not a fire because
people don't believe it like it's
the reason that we still have to fund
studies to say if you're born in certain
zip code you're gonna have like poor
life outcomes because people are still
like yeah exactly it's it's again it's
because if you believe in this myth of
hard work than people who aren't
impoverished are at fault and you have
to break that idea before you get people
motivated to do anything and and and
that's that's hard and it's true across
the board I mean like that idea lives in
my head somewhere it's still back there
is something I have to actively think
about talk about and fight against
because we all have these biases you
know a well socialized person is a
person who learns the norm of their
societies right those are our norms
that's what we've been taught that's how
we function in the world so it's hard to
like I don't know take the red pill or
whatever like look back and see how
things are actually going on yeah I you
know and I don't have the answer on a
global level because I know for myself
it was something that I was made very
aware of the role of the dice if you
will it wasn't something that I was
fully aware of until I got to college
until I understood just how different
people's dice could land but then mixing
that with knowing that my parents we
don't come from generational wealth
because my family is directly descended
from slaves we were coming from Florida
so my family but you know Louisiana in
Texas like slave trade happened right
there and so you know coming from a
house where it was a two-parent
household you know parents stayed
married till death did them part and I I
had an education because they said to me
you will you can go to college or you
can get a job and go to college and
those are your options after you turn 18
so when you have that mindset you know
being drilled into you from about the
age of six
it's a privilege it's truly a privilege
I love the way that I was raised and you
have to go out to the world and really
with that especially as a black person
as a black woman I could be the exact
same person that I am same looks have
the same ideas but if I were living on
any other side of this world right now
my circumstances could it be vastly
different just like that we haven't even
talked about pretty privileged honey
pretty privileged is like the best
privilege of whites get to that but just
the basic privilege to have a roof over
my head like I said college education I
I was the one that propositioned my dad
to like get me SAT courses because I was
scheming and I was like if you invest in
this then I'll get a scholarship and
then we don't have to pay for college
and then your money will like pay for
itself and it happened that's a
privilege so my goal now is recognizing
out of those machinations work to know
that I have the option of an SAT cheater
I wasn't told we can't afford that they
were told do you have a recommendation I
was like sure I'll just go back to my
private school where they're all getting
SAT tutors and just have one of them
come teach me it was that simple
and I recognize every single day that
people that are just like me do not have
that privilege and it's systemic why
they don't have that privilege I was the
only brown face I was still the only
brown face when I go into meetings it's
I was just at like a bunch of meetings
last week and I was like are y'all
serious right now like I'm really the
only black woman and this one black
person and I just have a vested interest
in mentorship like that is the that is
the thing I have found lacking in my
life that is the thing that I think we
should be giving back you have to like
each one reach one each month because
that's the only thing you can take
responsibility for each one reach one
teach one because that is the only thing
that we have actual control over we can
talk about gen Z till the cows come home
but until you are actually sitting there
talking to one and hearing what their
experience is like in this school system
that they're living in now you don't
know anything about that generation do
not presume from a news article that got
it so wrong with every other generation
to know you know yeah and I think
tell them and teach them and teach them
the importance of teaching the
generation that comes after them all of
the tricks and all of the slip-ups that
have come so that we don't end up
villainizing each other and trying to
continually blame one another for the
state of the world because we're all
unless you're under 18 and you haven't
had a chance to vote yet we're all
responsible so yeah and what you talking
about
like going to the private school knowing
that an SAT tutor is a thing like I
think setting expectations it's like
sort of more of an ephemeral idea than
like having food or having water and the
other things that we've been talking
about but the fact that our parents when
we are I don't know five six years old
are like what college are you going to
go to they're putting it in our head not
are you going to go to college like that
level of expectation setting of forming
your world and what the possibilities
are for your world is so important and
and so I think I don't again I don't
know how to solve that beyond actually
exposing people to more the other thing
that I would say on a super practical
basis we're talking about policy stuff
public schools are funded by real estate
taxes and that's bananas because if you
live in a poor area where people have
homes that are less expensive they don't
pay as much taxes less money is going to
the schools Wow and then I think about a
city like San Francisco where our real
estate taxes should be off the Richter
so that means that our education system
for public students should be off the
Richter as well it should be in it its
spoiler alert it's better than in some
other places for sure is so low in this
country for education it's yes but also
that's not an accident